un enfrentamiento armado en las calles
de cali a plena luz del día
el saldo tres muertos uno de ellos son
funcionarios públicos un empleado de la
fiscalía que abrió fuego vestido de
civil en otro municipio a las afueras
falleció una cuarta persona miembro de
la primera línea herido con arma blanca
en cali considerada el epicentro de las
protestas son varias las denuncias de
ataques armados por parte de civiles la
ciudad parece un territorio sin ley
desde el comienzo del paro nacional hace
ya un mes en colombia un panorama que
preocupa a organizaciones
internacionales están recargando el
presidente iván duque la situación en
cali es muy grave
te ruego tomar medidas urgentes para
escalar incluida una orden específica
prohibiendo el uso de armas de fuego por
parte de los agentes del estado el
presidente iván duque se desplazó al
sacarle en la noche del viernes para
anunciar un despliegue militar la
retórica de su gobierno desde el inicio
de las manifestaciones ha sido la de
reforzar la actuación de la policía y el
ejército pero con un discurso de condena
ligera de los abusos por parte de las
fuerzas de seguridad que este despliegue
llevará a casi a triplicar nuestra
capacidad menos de 24 horas en todo el
departamento asegurando una asistencia
también en puntos neurálgicos un mes de
paro ha logrado la retirada de la
reforma tributaria que desató las
protestas del 28 de abril al de la salud
del ministro de hacienda de la canciller
y del alto comisionado para la paz pero
no la del ministro de defensa
responsable también de la policía a
quien presuntamente se le atribuyen 43
homicidios en el marco de las protestas
para empezar
[Música]
la indignación por la represión y los
reclamos de derechos básicos siguen
llenando las calles pero el paro se
dirige hacia un punto incierto pues todo
parece indicar que el gobierno no tiene
ninguna intención de negociar porque
porque ellos lee que si siguen las
manifestaciones la clase media la clase
alta al final va a terminar votando otra
vez por ellos en las elecciones próximas
además del poder popular que cada vez
más se está organizando a nivel local
muchos manifestantes ven en las
elecciones del 2022 una posibilidad de
cambio de ciclo a nivel nacional